i'm like 29 i sold the business so when
you go through an acquisition you have a
closing date and then
all of a sudden this gigantic amount of
money just hits your bank account and
you're like
what the did i just do is this
legal like did i just sell
drugs some people think you just
celebrate and you're like i made it
yes i was like the opposite i grew up
poor
so going from like that to an absorbent
amount where i'm comfortable like i was
sick
i can literally buy a house cash the
first thing i did was i hired a wealth
manager to move all the money out of my
bank account
we just bought bonds i knew nothing
about bonds and then all of a sudden i'm
like why is there more money
and they're like yeah that's how bonds
used to work at least but
i used to go into the bank a few times
before that wire and i'd pull out like a
bill just so they can see my account
similarly we had this guy james hong who
created hot or not on the podcast he
said the same thing he goes i used to go
to an atm machine
and just put my card in and say print
balance and just look at it
he's like i would just do that like
every day for like the first like in a
week that it happened and then like go
about his day it just made him happy